here to promote the AC green Youth
Foundation is the man himself AC green
good to see you sir thank you appreciate
it you're wearing that t-shirt right now
the AC green AC green future generation
Leadership Program
absolutely I like it what size is that
t-shirt man this size is actually
probably about a 2x a 2x it's nice
comfortable - I could see that yes yeah
it looks good it looks out so what is
what is the AC green Youth Foundation
all about let's start with it all
actually started 27 years okay found it
right here in LA during seven years ago
27 years ago actually yes and so I
really focus really on education is
really big for me
character development it's also a huge
component of what we do
childhood obesity financial literacy all
those components go into sort of what we
do a year around and especially this
particular week there's about 250 kids
walking around this campus right here
right here in on the eighteen th new to
campus exactly today being able to take
a tour and see really little things that
happen inside these wonderful doors and
they're actually I do believe walking
directly behind us here on the 18 T
Studios if we can wave to them there
they go walking out so how many kids are
here did you brought it it's right at
250 kids division yeah it's pretty
exciting what it is we've got kids from
Salvation Army's Boys and Girls Clubs
the organization beyond the Bale as well
as a lot of LAUSD school districts kids
I think kids came from Arizona Arizona
facts of life these kids came all the
way from Phoenix and to be a part of
this particular week with us yeah and
just to give me a story so you're proud
of the kid that came from a certain
difficult spot and through your
organization has gone on to X Y & Z
based on all of that what God for me a
see honestly I mean a kid today right
now this Trey Carlisle in in Trey you
know he grew up with two wonderful
parents and that's a great thing and so
it's not a sort of a rags to riches type
story but it's the important thing is
Trey saw a nice model inside of his home
I grew up you know right in a middle
class type neighborhood but the
beautiful thing in the in the almost
five eight years he's been a part of our
program
he's got the idea you know what I want
to give back I want to be a part and
it's not the camp is free so there's no
charge to come to my particular camps in
all these years but he's been able to
get the picture that is you want to pass
things on so he's been able now sixteen
years old
seventeen okay he's come back he's now
actually one of my volunteers who's
leading work at the camp this particular
week and so he's now the guy in front of
the camp as opposed to a guy sitting on
the floor watching me do it is leading
it's one kind of a [ __ ] that's got to be
so gratified yeah honestly it really is
a AC green here on the Rich Eisen show a
part of me I gotta be honest with you
despite whatever story I knew whatever
story you're going to tell me was going
to be inspiring to say the least
part of me was hoping that well there
was this young man named levar ball and
he came to the AC green Youth Foundation
and then he had he had Lonzo yeah you
know and except now there's issue what
do you what do you make of the ball
hullabaloo that is its grip this town AC
there's no other way to put it and
nationally nationally it is something
that everybody's looking at that magic
went ahead and drafted
Lonzo and what's going to happen this
fall what do you make of all of it soup
to nuts you know it is just that it's an
A to Z type story you know it's a father
loving his kids and promoting these kids
you know that that parent watching the
kids and my kids the best as he's in the
audience watching the kids do whatever
it is and then he's just gone to another
level he's using some of our technology
and media forces today to go on and do
the same things it's just happening now
catch on and go little biro go little
global but at the end of the day it
really does always come down to the
talent it comes down to the efficiency
on the field on the court you know
playing volleyball swimming whatever
that child is doing and the knowledge
you know Lonzo had to now live up to all
the hype that his dad has been creating
and he's trying to separate himself at
the same time but I understand his dad's
being a dad what did what do you think
how do you think urban magic will be
able what will happen the minute that
levar does not throughout stay in his
Lane to use his parlance what do you
that will happen knowing magic is
obviously as well as you do well I would
put like this
Lavar is not one of Magic's employees
and Majid understands that so you can't
fire them but at the same time I know
there will be a direct conversation
saying you know what this field is part
of the brand that I'm responsible for
and we probably need to have a long talk
do you think he's had that conversation
with the moon
no I don't think so because I don't
think levar has really got to that point
yet no you know and you maybe maybe he
won't
well I don't know you know how this goes
absolutely
you can hang as many Summerlee
championship banners if that's what you
do with them right but game 18 I'm
Brooke I'm Tony Envy Ironman 1935 49 62
I mean it's a slog here and at some
point the minutes might not be there or
a benching might take place for a lesson
it Luke Walton has every right to do as
the coach and everyone's kind of
expecting that this thing to come oh
yeah oh yeah and so you're right you
know you're trying to forecast you know
and trying to get ahead of that
particular curve it's going to write
something it will happen somewhere
something will ignite it but at the same
time magic it's a good thing about it he
has that temperament he understands the
big picture what we're really trying to
go as a Laker family Laker nation and so
I think that conversation will come
hopefully won't be in the midst of the
fire but I think it will come and I
think it won't be as you know
detrimental because I think you know
they probably would have a meeting of
the minds I'm not going to say they're
going to agree on a blue cent one of
those definitely disagree to agree m.a.c
Green is here on the Rich Eisen show and
go to AC Green Comm for more about the
AC green youth foundation we've got 250
kids from the AC green youth foundation
here on the campus of 80 right here on
the Rich Eisen show who do you stay in
touch with the most who are you tightest
with from back in the Lakers day well
you speak to you know rich the thing is
I'm still around the team around the
organization so I still go to our local
practice I don't take the road trips so
I'll just read here in Michigan on the
street yeah okay love it being over
there and so I get a chance to go to
practices watch and stay connected with
the guys get my input where I can but
I'm also one of our studio analysts
you know so when we're doing studio work
and then also I'm a color commentator
for the d-league team the Lakers delete
in the South Bay defenders so were the
magic are the ones that you're tightest
with you think magic worthy I still see
buying all the time Michael Cooper still
all the time Michael Thompson yes I
don't see cream as much because he
doesn't do as much and so the core guys
are still here we're still well well
connected so I put you guys out on the
floor again right now yeah go ahead
let me hear this yeah who do you be well
we'll get a run for the money with the
Warriors I will honestly say that and I
honestly say the Cavs will probably but
I say even to this particular data war
warriors Cavs and probably the Spurs but
I think the rest of them will take them
deep into a series right now today of
course today today we go down the street
Magic's there were these they're
Cooper's there we get firing back in the
building yes you're there
who else Michael Thompson we get him
talk yet we'll still bring in the big
fella
okay he still wants to throw a few
Rambis we get Rambis in this mix Curt
might want to fight too much right now
okay yeah I'm just gonna round those
Knicks so we got it like what I want to
triangular somehow and you you would you
and you and the Warriors Cavs and spurs
might get you got the rest of the other
27 teams of the Association you got them
not scared I'll bring them four quarters
I don't buy that that is a full quarter
okay so it's so one quarter you're
getting you take these guys how about
the first time out okay we got oh okay
do you ever what when you look back on
those years woody what what leaves to
mind a see like what pops to mind we're
not just thinking you know what honestly
Brotherhood friendship it's a fraternity
I'll never never in and it's a beautiful
thing all the road trips you know just
just wonderful honestly really a lot of
my kids on the bus as I was riding the
school bus over here to your show today
they were asking me some of the favorite
moments and memories and I was telling
us so you know the friendships that you
build with the guys who said it's like
you guys meeting each other in camp you
guys stay in contact you never know how
long and who can become your best friend
and when you see these warriors right
now do you see some of the Showtime
Lakers and what you see because it's
about sharing ball movement fluidity
fluidity in a way that that kind of is
REM what you say it's reminiscent tell
Richie brought unemployment really I
mean the Warriors and the Spurs they
move that ball like none other and so it
does remind me of my team it's a bunch
of Magic Johnson's out there as far as
the idea of moving the ball first
before trying to score first and it's a
it's a good thing to see I get excited
when I watch those teams play for that
very reason I mean it's exciting to see
individual talent but just how they play
together is cool I've got about a minute
and a half left when you see players
star players resting and rest what do
you think is the NBA Iron Man for they
take time off you know that's how
today's society and today's player and
the technology today as far as the
analytics that go into the game it's
saying you know this is a good thing for
today's player in the modern day air
fine I have no problem with it
thumpers crazy I mean personally but
it's cool let him just go ahead and do
what they do you missed three games in
your career your career you miss three
that's true that's true
and you never once said you know I'm
tired on the I just need time because I
know if we're gonna go deep into the
playoffs well the thing about it Phil
Jackson nor coach Raleigh would ever
listen to me so that was the thing about
it bigs it's like get in there
ac thanks for coming in here ac Green
Comm for more of the AC green youth
foundation I know that you're gonna
bring your kids into the studio
absolutely my casa is your casa we're
just thank you you know we're just we're
just up the street and if you want me to
if you want me to if you want me to talk
to Lanza and levar I'm here all right
three eye proofs melt them down or
anything else obviously thank you roots
you got it thanks for coming on at NBA
underscore iron man here on the Rich
Eisen show want to thank Kenny Florian
Jerome Bettis Jim Breuer and AC green
for joining me here tomorrow show
Reginald Martinez Jackson mr. October
part of our guest right here in the
middle of July thanks for coming in it
come back tomorrow come back come on
back at the great here the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint